the entire kind of arc of human history
has really been defined by how we
harness and capture energy you know
initially starting with us leveraging
things like fire and then later coal and
petroleum fuel sources for our energy
needs and really the great opportunity
going forward is this idea that we can
capture renewable energy sources store
that energy in batteries and then use
that to power our lives
advances in battery design over the past
few decades have made modern technology
possible
but it's not enough
we need better cheaper more energy dense
batteries if we're going to make
electric cars ubiquitous and save the
planet
now companies are on the verge of
battery breakthroughs that could change
the world
the battery industry has been kind of
stuck making batteries one way for like
50 years and we think it's just time for
that to change
a battery looks like a black box quite
literally sometimes
but inside it is a very complex mixture
of chemicals
there are four components
there are two electrodes cathode and
anode there's a separator and then
there's a liquid electrolyte typically
and the electrolytes job is to be able
to shuttle
ions between the two electrodes
and that's what charges the battery and
that's what allows the battery to be
then discharged and produce power
among the everyday technologies
batteries are perhaps one of the oldest
because
batteries were invented even before
electricity
was invented which is to say there was
no way to generate electricity until
somebody made a battery and that was
back in 1799
by an italian scientist named volta
and what he created was actually
called a voltaic pile it wasn't even
called a battery back then
it was called a pile because it was
literally a pile of two different types
of metal in this case copper and zinc
separated by
typically a piece of cardboard that was
dipped in vinegar
to get a feel for how a battery works we
decided to build our own i got a copper
sheet i got a couple zinc sheets uh i
cut them into one by one squares and i
also got a coffee filter that i cut into
one inch squares too
right just to start off uh keep a simple
aluminium foil
at the bottom so that you're able to
test whether the battery is working or
not on top you put a copper sheet and so
now you have to dip the coffee filter
into a solution of salt and water okay
then you put your coffee filter
done and then
you place the zinc sheet on top
you also have a voltmeter which
basically will be able to measure the
voltage that this battery will have okay
so we're getting 0.74 volts
yeah that sounds about right yeah um
now you can connect a copper cable
on either ends
and you could solder that on then you
can connect it to say an led light
and that should light up
the more cells you pile on the higher
the voltage
we piled on 10 layers of zinc and copper
to see if we could power up an led light
so let's test it with
an led light okay
it's the moment of truth here
there we go
and that's electricity
cool
batteries have come a long way since the
voltaic pile but they're still made up
of the four basic components
anode cathode separator and electrolyte
the current state-of-the-art lithium-ion
battery is small light and relatively
powerful making everything from mobile
devices to electric cars possible
but in order to make decarbonization a
reality batteries need to get much much
better
we are quite far away from the limits of
what a battery can do among the
different things about batteries that
still need to be improved is not just
the amount of energy they can store
but they also have to do it safely
batteries also need to
be
charged more quickly and finally
batteries still aren't cheap enough they
probably need to be half the price to be
able to compete with the
gasoline-powered engine
to accomplish all that a number of
companies are going inside the black box
and tinkering with those four basic
components hoping to jump start the next
generation of batteries batteries have a
long history of pretty slow improvement
on the order of four to five percent a
year i think we're one of the few
companies that are actually trying to do
something pretty revolutionary in the
space
harold rusk's company anovix based just
south of san francisco is making one
seemingly small tweak to the lithium-ion
battery
replacing the anode typically made of
carbon with silicon so the major
advantage of silicon is it has three
times the energy density of carbon which
it replaces so that allows you to pack
more stuff in your battery and drive up
energy density but silicon while it's a
great anode
suffers from a bunch of problems the
biggest of which is the fact that it
expands 300
easy way to think about it is when
you're charging a cell the silicon tends
to expand and when you discharge it
it compresses or contracts
that's a potentially battery busting
problem but the novx claims to have
found a solution
a complex method of arranging the
battery's components that keeps the
silicon under pressure
this 3d architecture allows us to
constrain that expansion in a very
uniform way within the cell that allows
us to maintain a very long cycle life it
allows us to basically
manage that swelling without any
macroscopic growth of the battery
a silicon anode battery could store
about 50 percent more energy than what's
currently on the market
which could mean we'll be seeing lighter
electronics with longer battery life in
the near future
we've been actively sampling batteries
over the last two years to customers
we're sitting in a room now where we're
starting to assemble our first
production line and right now we're
targeting you know first deliveries
towards the towards the end of this year
we're focused on consumer electronics to
start we the technology is definitely
applicable to larger battery
applications like ebs potentially grid
storage and so that's on our roadmap
[Music]
elsewhere in silicon valley another
company is working on an even more
ambitious battery design
we started with the mission of trying to
narrow the gap between combustion engine
based vehicles and evs and we recognized
that the key there was to build a better
battery we could usher in a new era of
transportation
15-minute charge times better life
performance and even lower costs turns
out all those problems can be addressed
if you just switch from a carbon or
carbon silicon anode to a lithium metal
anode
usually the lithium in lithium ion
batteries only refers to the molecule
shuttling between the cathode and anode
making the anode itself out of lithium
could double the energy density of the
battery
a much bigger leap than a silicon anode
battery like anovix's we didn't invent
the idea of a lithium metal battery that
idea has been around for a very long
time even before lithium-ion lithium
metal batteries were used there's just
one small problem
unfortunately they're not safe
so typically inside a battery the
electrolyte is liquid but and liquid
electrolyte for a lithium metal battery
causes the lithium metal to degrade and
sometimes even shot and catch fire
quantum scape's main goal was to try and
replace what is a liquid electrolyte
inside the battery with a solid
electrolyte the problem is that no one
has been able to make one that conducts
well enough
to compete with the liquid wasn't clear
that even the material existed in nature
that could meet these requirements so we
had to explore a wide range of materials
but luckily nature had a material that
meets requirements and our team was able
to find it
it's literally a solid material it's a
ceramic material but it's it's kind of a
very special material because lithium
ions can just zip right through it like
they're on a highway
this single pouch cell is all quantum
scape was able to show us of their solid
state battery ultimately they'll stack
100 of these together to make a complete
battery pack
the company is still a few years from
selling a commercial product
but the performance improvements they're
predicting would be revolutionary
[Music]
we've shown that we can charge faster
you can get eighty percent charge in 15
minutes which is going to be really
important if you're on the road trip or
if you don't have a garage to plug your
car in and charge overnight you can get
longer range by improving the energy
density of the battery what we've said
is we're aiming to have cars driving
with these cells in 2024
so the next few years will be about
increasing the the scale of production
we formed a partnership with volkswagen
in 2012 and they've announced that they
would partner with us and and make a
joint venture to commercialize the cells
and go into manufacturing together
we think that with these batteries
you're going to be able to get evs that
compete more effectively with combustion
engine based uh vehicles
you get more energy density uh you have
lower cost and longer life
so our mission right now is you know is
to get these batteries on the road uh
try to really transform the automotive
sector
and in the process really make a dent on
co2 emissions
companies like quantumscape and innovix
are imagining a future in which clean
affordable evs dominate the roads
but the implications go much further
than that
better batteries are key to almost every
technology that could slow down climate
change
batteries are what are known as an
enabling technology which is that you
can use a battery to
make an impact across different sectors
of the economy
and across different types of
technologies so currently our batteries
can go in electric cars but there's
still a battery that needs to go in a
truck
then there needs to be a battery that
goes in a ship and then there needs to
be a battery that could go in a plane
there are now bigger and bigger
batteries being put on the grid
uh that help us increase the amount of
renewables we consume
and all those things
get a boost
with every little innovation that
happens in that place and so the impact
that batteries can have
is immense
you